community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
southwest medical and associates the
sponsors of this segment are back with
another community partnership to
celebrate their 50th anniversary take a
look
tony corbin of southwest medical and
kelly christo of project 150 welcome to
las vegas now
thank you
tony we are celebrating the 50th
anniversary all year long for southwest
medical and we're partnering with
different organizations celebrating with
them this time it's project 150 but
let's start with you what do you do for
southwest medical
well good morning and i am the chief
operating officer and i have the
responsibility for clinic operations at
southwest medical which includes over
375 000 patients and i'm excited to
celebrate southwest medical's 50th
anniversary i'm proud to be part of this
medical group for 31 years now that's
just so hard for me to believe but um
every day when i step through the door
at southwest medical i feel that i'm
making a difference in our patients
lives i truly am living my best career
dream being part of a dynamic
ever-changing healthcare system whose
mission is to continually improve
healthcare
when i first started at southwest
medical there were only two medical
clinics that's really hard for me to
believe just too right and i'm so proud
of what we've built the largest medical
specialty group in the state with the
best in class quality of care for the
patients we serve
but we're not alone in caring for our
community and that is why we are taking
this year
southwest medical's 50th anniversary as
an opportunity to share with other
community partners who also have a
strong history of giving back to our
community and we are excited about our
community partnership with project 150.
all right well that is the perfect segue
to kelly the executive director of
project 150 tell us
what your organization does for the
community
of course so project 150 provides basic
necessities to homeless displaced and
disadvantaged high school students here
in southern nevada and northern nevada
we've been doing that for 11 years now
so our mission is to make sure that
these students have all their basic
necessities so that they continue to go
to school graduate and then we work with
them on scholarships in college and and
moving on to build a successful future
that is incredible work thank you kelly
for what you do um how can people help
you and your organization
there's so many ways to help us um we
love volunteers so every day we have
groups in our building that are
assisting making family meal bags
sorting clothes that go into betty's
boutique
just doing a variety of different things
there's also ways to support us for any
of the events we have we have our fall
fundraiser coming up in september um
financial contributions obviously help
they give us our our buying power to
purchase the food that we need to
continue to supply the students all year
round um so tons of ways to get involved
with us you just gotta check us out on
our website
that is a great organization thank you
to southwest medical for sponsoring that
segment